if you're a property investor and you're
worried about the new tax changes and
the new legislations that are coming in
then this video is for you my name is
Samuel Leeds I'm a property investor and
I'm the best-selling author of a book by
low rent hi and I wanted to explain why
I love the new tax changes and how about
watching this video the tax changes will
actually benefit you rather than India
let me just explain exactly what they
are the new changes that are coming in
I'm going to say that your mortgage
payments I'm no longer tax deductible
which means you're going to lose out
because you can only play back the tax
oh my goodness what do we do well let's
say you had a property and your rent was
500 pounds a month and your mortgage
payments were 300 pounds a month which
would leave you with a profit of 200
pounds a month which is what you would
pay tax on however where these new
changes come in you'll have to pay tax
on the whole five hundred pounds which
means that you could be left
shortchanged out-of-pocket and if you
rely on your renter's income you could
be left broke so what's the solution
shall we note about it Chewie throw
tantrums and parade the street saying we
hate the other ones screw the people
make up the rules or should we say hmm
maybe the people who make up the rules
are the same people who make money in
property maybe there's a loophole but my
friends there is a loophole in this a
works if you are a business and you buy
your properties through a business
meaning a limited company the tax rules
no longer apply and guess what they made
another rule because we're all over here
changes for the bad another wall over
here changes for the good but what
happens is the media and anyone learn so
much about this rule they forget this
one if you buy for a business it doesn't
apply and they change the rules to say
that buying through a business is
suddenly a doddle anybody can do it you
could set up a company today in about 20
minutes they'll cost you
fifteen pounds and tomorrow you can buy
a house through that business no
questions asked no problem virgin
company and the way they do it is they
say that this is the company buying the
property but the investor acts as a
guarantor on the company how cool that
so the tax problems evolve moaning about
where you can continue buying properties
and the tax rules will not apply
whatsoever for you kids never think the
properties that I buy in the hoenn i buy
them low i read them by my mortgage
payments are not 300 and my read 500 my
mortgage payments are 200 and my weight
is 1500 pounds so the tax changes on my
existing portfolio are only going to
actually affect me by about 20 pounds
per month per property no big deal so
that explains what I'm not worried about
the new tax changes but let me tell you
why I love the new tax changes if you're
an amateur landlord and these tax
changes are crippling getting you don't
know some of this stuff what are you
going to do are you just gonna go broke
are you just gonna bend over and take it
by the government' their income will
have disappeared so they will have to
pass that bill I'll see you who the
tenant which means that rents will go up
all these amateurs I'll also having to
put their rents up which means that I
can put my rents up too and the tax
rules don't even apply to me because
I've got very small mortgages and I'm
binary limited company so actually the
smart investors you are the winners
people sometimes say hmm what about
interest rates go up interest rates you
can fix currently for 10 years the only
thing that's going up anytime soon our
house prices and rents which is why I
would say to you get a limited company
build your property portfolio like crazy
and watch rents rise and you become
financially free I hope that's helpful
the step Julie changes that's a little
problem the last house that I bought
five bed hmm in Wolverhampton
I paid zero stamp duty on 130
five thousand five hours no stamp duty
do you want to figure out how to do more
things get more tips and suggestions I
would suggest that you subscribe to this
channel enjoy the videos and hope to
meet you in person
at the property investors crash course
one day